so the first thing you need to do in
order to reach your potential or do what
you're really meant to do is understand
your own strengths and weaknesses and it
turns out that most people I talk to do
not know their strengths and weaknesses
they maybe can take a stab at their
strengths but they have a tough time
writing down their weaknesses the trap
people fall in often is they say I'm in
a class of 50 other people or I'm in a
job with 20 other peers and I ought to
be able to be good at everything they're
good at if they're good at something
that I want to be good at and the
reality is every every person is good at
certain things to a certain degree and
not as good at others the trick is to
figure out your strengths and weaknesses
and what the things are you need to
improve on you have to assess them
versus a specific job if I want to be a
newspaper reporter there are certain
sets of strengths and weaknesses I need
if I want to be an investment banker
it's a difference that if I want to be a
college professor it's another set so
you need to understand your own
strengths and weaknesses and then
calibrate it to what you need to do very
well to be outstanding in that job
figuring out your strengths and
weaknesses probably is not something you
can do all by yourself you need to get
advice and observations from people who
watch you who see you in action and can
point out to you what you're good at and
what you're not good at and the reason
it helps to get advice from others is we
all have blind spots problem is it has
to be skill based it can't be amorphous
it can't be generalized needs to be
based on skills that are relevant to
whatever task you're doing and then
ideally a coach would give you some
advice on techniques for improving those
skills you need to be open to hearing
things that you don't want to hear and
you need to not send off a vibe that you
don't want to hear feedback the mistakes
people make is they either don't
understand their own strengths and
weaknesses they're not willing to get
advice from others to get feedback on
what they're really good at and they
don't calibrate it against a job what I
mean trying to encourage people to do is
do this systematically because your
strengths and your weaknesses are really
the building blocks
of what whatever whatever you're going
to try to do